So guys, let's talk about the zoom clothes really quick and when to schedule it said
I want to I want to reiterate and you know spring this up again.
I've talked about this already.
It's not when to actually do the clothes is going to be more of a gut feeling than it
is an exact science.
Okay.
It's not you know necessarily after X amount of leads on this day and blah blah blah.
It's not like that.
Okay.
It's you're going to feel it.
You're going to know the customer is going to start saying things.
They're going to start acting a certain way and you're just going to feel hey it's time
to go and when the iron is hot it's time to strike.
Okay.
And sometimes it's going to be inconvenient.
Sometimes you're going to be leaving for Cancun tomorrow at nine in the morning and you're
going to need to wake up early to do the call close the deal and get to the airport on time
and it sucks.
Okay.
But you know what it feels that flight is a lot better when I've made money than when
I have it.
So I deal with it.
Okay.
That's number one.
The other thing I want to bring this up here is we want to make sure to send the screencast
the night before.
Want to give them at least 24 hours to watch this screencast.
Okay.
So let's say for example that tomorrow was because today is actually Wednesday.
Let's say tomorrow's Thursday.
We're supposed to do the call tomorrow at noon.
Okay.
I would want to make sure that my screencast was made and sent within at least 24 hours
before and I would send them have it attached to a software that tracks it and I would want
to give them 24 hours to watch this video but I would want to schedule it you know for
tomorrow at noon and I would want to send it before 24 hours before.
Okay.
Very very simple.
The other thing I want to mention is make sure that's actually kind of a bad example
because I like to make sure and schedule my zoom closes either first thing in the morning
or in the evening.
Okay.
Morning is always better but I'm talking their morning.
So I'm you know mountain time if I'm doing someone in the eastern time I'm doing these
calls early and the reason why is guys when you set appointments for their lunch break
life happens man business happens employee problems and I got hung up on a job and blah
and then they're just like do I really want to deal with this do I really want to take
time out of my day to get pitched but if you do it first thing in the morning and it's
like before they go out to work they're going to they've already agreed to it.
That's a different story.
Okay.
On top of that when you do it in the middle of the day.
What are they going to actually what are going to carry their laptop and catch you in the
parking lot of a 7-eleven.
You know what I mean.
But at night or in the morning they're at their house they're at least on their laptop
or even if it's their phone but they're sitting down and they're able to focus.
Another great time to schedule these on Saturdays okay.
For me personally Saturdays are a day that I work on my business not in my business and
so for some of these business owners that's exactly what they do Saturday they don't got
employees they don't have Saturdays they don't have employees calling them ringing
them up customers aren't calling them as much.
So Saturdays are also a really good time to schedule these last few things I want to mention
here that are best practices is make sure to let them know like it's a very simple process
some of these people they get really scared when you talk about zoom in a video call and
just let them know say hey we're going to talk tomorrow what I'm going to do is I'm
going to send you an email it's going to have a link and all you're going to do is it's
really simple Mr. Business Owner you're just going to click on the link and it's going
to take you to a video okay really simple don't stress it and by the way if we have
problems we'll deal with it but it's not as complicated as it sounds so that's number
one is I let them know that and make sure and we'll talk about this in future videos
make sure that you can see their face and you can hear their voice because if I have
to get on and pitch somebody that won't even show their face how do you think I'm going
to get a credit card from somebody that won't even show their face okay.
So these are just some of the best practices with setting up the zoom clothes and when
to send the screencast so in recap set up the zoom clothes for morning or night when
they're at home focused make sure they're at a desktop okay make sure that they understand
zoom is going to be very simple it's going to be them clicking on a button make sure
you can see their face make sure you can hear their voice and make sure they've watched
the screencast that you just created that's 10 minutes or less that they've watched that
or sorry at least 24 hours before or you've sent that sent it to them 24 hours before
and they have watched the screencast before you get if you don't do this guys you're you're
every one of these things that you don't do you can still close deals and you probably
will still close deals by skipping steps but the more of these things that you do the closer
to this process the higher the chance of you actually getting the deal